il reste si peu de Jedi
[Musique]
elle arrive
nos ennemis se multiplient
une galaxie n'est pas sûre
pourrait utiliser l'aide c'est maintenant ou jamais
une fois que le rebelle est toujours un rebelle les
traque c'est là que ça devient
intéressant préparez-vous prêt
Ahsoka deux épisodes première le 23 août
uniquement sur Disney Plus
[Musique]
fais toujours il n'y a ni plus ni moins
un maître
et un apprenti
fais attention à la force vive jeune
Padawan
[Musique]
tu te laisseras tenter par le côté obscur de
la Force
One Must  Détruire pour créer
plus vite ça fait un moment les choses ont
changé
parfois il faut faire ce qui est juste
chasser la peur est le destin d'un Jedi attacher sa
ceinture n'ayez jamais peur de qui vous êtes
chez vous mais vous avez appris que
nous avons ce qu'ils grandissent au-delà de
ça  est le véritable fardeau de tous les
deux épisodes de Masters Ahsoka diffusés en streaming le
23 août sur Disney Plus